let's revisit specificity and sensitivity, and see how it is calculated.
In the language of hypothesis testing we can have the classification problem
expressed as a hypothesis I or class 1, and a hypothesis II as class 2.
Often one of the hypothesis is called the null hypothesis and
the other the alternate hypothesis.
In our example, we can say hypothesis I as the person is B,
and hypothesis II as the person is F.
This is the case of a binary classifier.
Now recall, we had two kinds of errors defined.
The type 1 error and the type 2 error.
The type 2 error is the one minus the the specificity.
The model inherently classifies between the two classes or hypothesis.
By making a cut or a threshold.
In this case, let's put the threshold as 1.5.
With this cut, we can
calculate the area under the probability distribution of both the hypothesis.
If the Type 1 error for given cut or test disket.
For a given hypothesis, is less than a pre-determined value called significance,
which is expressed as a probability of the classifier,
we fail to reject that class.
We also claim that as failing to reject the null hypothesis.
We also define the power of the test as 1
minus the sensitivity of the type 2 error.
Now notice the sensitivity and
the specificity is dependent on the threshold or the cut determined here.
If we move this around, the values for sensitivity and specificity.
With change.
You can guess now, that we can draw a curve that
plots the specificity versus sensitivity for different values of this cut.
Such a curve is called a receiver operator characteristic curve.
In the following video, we will look at an ROC curve for our classifiers.